greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by on it for all your supplemental
needs go to Honda listen I can't hook
you up with the kettle bells and [ __ ]
ropes and battle ropes and that [ __ ] but
as far as supplements are concerned the
jerky the [ __ ] hemp protein the
shroom tech support and the shroom tech
immune the alpha brain the core of the
organization
I'll get you 10% on just go to alikom
right now in press in church BAM let's
get to living right the house no drama
nobody knows nothing w ask questions you
understand me number two listen your
people always hit me up Joey what do I
got a fat man G where's the best key for
a fat guy listen I'm gonna hand it to
you right now Fuji
they've been around since Japan got
bombed they don't give a [ __ ] you
understand me
Fuji sports.com has been there forever
they've been making [ __ ] a Muay Thai
gear they got mats they got everything
they got the best guy in the business
how do I know cuz that's all I wear and
then whatever I'm in close God people
try to pull me pull me they try to
[ __ ] grab my arm those [ __ ] G's
adorable those kids are strong you
understand me jack so whether you're
looking for shin guards whether you're
looking for a nice rash guard whether
you're looking for a nice guy if you
need a raster on your 5x
guess who got it fuji sports comm press
in church BAM get 10% off delivered to
your house tell them uncle Joey Sencha
all right kick this [ __ ] melee as the
church always happening now Tuesday
morning you bad [ __ ] as I missed
you long week last week I want to thank
Providence and the comedy connection for
having me last week two sold-out shows
and then my man [ __ ] of any branch
stress factory you guys were phenomenal
I'm sorry about the heckler Friday night
Late Show he threw my timing off you
know I'm definitely one [ __ ] here [ __ ]
the topic then this guy wouldn't shut
the [ __ ] up but that's it and that's
that I had a great time thank you very
much for making my homecoming always a
[ __ ] pleasure on the way back I had
the pleasure of flying back with Kate
Quigley and Andrew Dice Clay on JetBlue
Andrew Dice Clay is the funniest man
alive he's giving away free don't hop
bagels on the [ __ ] flight two people
and two chicks actually took
[ __ ] beggars no [ __ ] earlier it
wasn't two guys it was two broads took
the [ __ ] bagels unbeliev imagine
getting a bagel from the dice at 6:00 in
the morning like before we were on that
plane that [ __ ] four we boarded that
[ __ ] five to 8:15 a.m. oh my
god up all night I went over my brother
pick me up in New Brunswick yeah I gotta
hand it to George you know I've known
him since I was [ __ ] 15 the summer of
79 I've known that and but he's such a
[ __ ] family like you know he saved my
life he's another guy yeah but he picked
me up a new branch we went back to his
house he made fresh chicken cutlets
Italian style with the bread crumbs then
I must have had 18 of them and then he
whips out a [ __ ] box from Rispoli so
a bakery on the famous Baker yeah and he
got two lobster tails in the [ __ ]
cannoli in that [ __ ] this
lobster tail has his velvet cream that
[ __ ] I didn't care about points
I'm gonna say [ __ ] [ __ ] la done then he
brought me some double caffeine Starbuck
coffee or some [ __ ] I drank that with
the [ __ ] lobster tail I was off and
running we stayed there till 3:45 to the
car came and got me the car came and got
me at 3:30 a.m.
it was just 12:30 yeah you know a dear
friend of mine travels a lot and I asked
her how she deals with stuff and she
said that she always stays on that way
time when she travels regardless or your
people want and that was always weird to
me I don't I find it I try to go to bed
at 12:00
then [ __ ] I know it sucks dick
but anyway who gives them [ __ ] the theme
is revenge I was talking to Ricky few
weeks ago we're talking my movies and
told him I wanted them back on the film
yeah back on the podcast and you know
why have Rick I love you nothing gonna
discuss films I'm not gonna have Rick
come on and talk about baseball so I was
thinking about how many films I like
that are about revenge
yeah but then after I spoke to you I
thought about revenge from many
different angles
like if you watch Rocky
yeah it's about revenge it's about a guy
getting one shot there's some yes so
many themes for revenge
it's thematically it's like everything
has been against me for so long people
have been [ __ ] on me people have
been saying that he isn't worth a [ __ ]
and yet I got a believe in me cuz I'm
like the only person that will and
whereas other people will write [ __ ] off
or will allow they'll allow the [ __ ] to
come down on them I'm gonna finally get
my balls back and say no not this time
it's gonna be different this time that's
you're absolutely right it's a revenge
against the self it's a revenge against
everybody who was said it's a revenge
against Mickey it's revenge a belt
against the leg breaking and the [ __ ]
fight game as a whole that it's a
beautiful example of that yeah that was
crazy I can't hit me I said some on the
periscope this morning and the Greek
kept me up from Toronto he was like
[ __ ] did you think about Godfather
too and I'm thinking about even
Godfather as a whole you know it's true
like he waited in the bushes yeah for 50
[ __ ] years never you know he went
back there and stabbed God which is a
tremendous scene and it's great too
because the guy is damn near death as it
is but Vito needs to be the one Vito
needs this guy and he lets him know Vito
Andolini you know I you know I come from
this place and this is for you
cut some write the [ __ ] a sudden
[ __ ] thesis and crazy she cuts up from
the lower father in the main clip they
don't show when he blows up the guy that
let he blows up the guy in the pizza
parlor yeah in Buffalo New York
they don't show them the rear in the
movie cutting the Phoenix I know but
when you get the ones with the added
scenes and then cut out which if you
watch the movie and you see some of the
other scenes you wished if they stay the
[ __ ] out especially a lot of James Caan
scenes yeah yeah they were pretty
[ __ ] bad well that's the thing with
these but these sometimes these
directors go back I mean I mean [ __ ]
Coppola did it with Apocalypse I mean
some of this [ __ ] that he put back in
was good some of that [ __ ] that that
whole plantation scene I mean goddamn it
just sold the movie downloaded not me I
understand what he's trying to do
with it but if the idea of it is good
and the execution is bad you gotta just
keep it out of there who are your
favourite directors right now right now
I still love Gilliam I still love
Scorsese Fincher hasn't made anything
really great in a long time but but now
it's just like a free-for-all it's like
everything that's it's almost like these
these these directors these directors
don't exist on that same level as you're
like oh [ __ ] there's gonna be a Scorsese
film coming out it's not like like
remember when Goodfellas came out and
you were like [ __ ] this is gonna be this
is Scorsese going back to what he knows
and then I would go and see
kundan or age of innocence or bringing
out the dead anything that the man did
it was do was the passion of that I know
Terry Gilliam was finally getting ready
to make the man who killed Don Quixote
which from the previews doesn't look
like it's gonna be very good but this
guy for years has always impressed me
with his visual sense you know but like
right now I can't say that there's too
many young directors I mean Fincher's
already in his 50s
Christopher Nolan is already up there
who the [ __ ] is out there making great
films you know I'm it's it's almost it's
almost impossible to pin it down to one
director doing really good work let's go
back a second here yeah because this is
something that I wanted to discuss
that's been bothering me for a long time
you know Lee and you Lee asked you when
we came in before the podcast started
about the movie passes [ __ ] yeah and
it's so weird he also asked you a really
weak question which a lot of people
don't ask of Lee's age he has you in the
new Beverly was gonna real yeah
listen let's draw cards on the table
here
I [ __ ] grew up in a movie theater
yeah I grew up on the movie theater and
the movie experience was easy yeah I was
like everything else in this life you
know flying used to be a breeze you
could smoke in the air you could drink
in there you gotta [ __ ] up you could
get up and sit with your friend and then
they ruined it you know every
this [ __ ] everything has become this
[ __ ] semi communistic if you saw life
back then you see how much freedom has
been taken from the only waste in the
videos to the [ __ ] to the [ __ ]
hemispheres one of those things that the
kids have with the cameras now you know
you can't commit a little jig crime oh
yeah the Thrones yeah yeah you commit a
crime they find the body they tap into a
camera they'll find you they'll see you
digging that [ __ ] drone don't
everything everything is DN everything
[ __ ] tape so even the movie theater
experience he has been taken from us the
movie experience what Lee said to you
well some of the movies have selected
seceding mm-hmm
science Edie are you talking about oh
yeah I said what the [ __ ] I want not
anymore not anymore do I see what I want
yeah you would like to but places like
the ArcLight places like some of the AMC
theater of our canal is to be honest I
like it I like what they're doing I like
the comfortable seats but the issue I
have with movies right now and the
reason why like don't I wouldn't go to
movies with that movie pass is a month
thing they're bad because that everyone
says movies are bad now but it seems
like they went from making like films or
store like full-on like worlds yeah and
now they're just making like themes like
oh this movie is a love story with with
with a comedic lobster and this one like
they had an emoji movie you know they
have the Kong movie which I heard with
the rock wasn't terrible but like it's
just a way for the rock to to blows it's
not to be the rock doing what the rock
doesn't so I'm gonna be CGI but the
thing is that when you when you find I
love old movies and the fact of the
matter is they are better movies they're
better stories they were told better
they were told with more heart and
passion but you also had actors that you
and I could relate to these were actors
that you wanted to be you wanted to be
Lee Marvin you wanted to be Bronson
there's not an actor working today that
I look at going yeah that that's a cool
[ __ ] that I wish I could be for
a minute you know
there one thing most of the people who
listen to this show yeah a young young
people and you don't want to sound like
that guy I never want to sound like that
guy that Oh 30 years ago you should have
seen but in many ways mm-hmm it's it's
an eye-opening experience when you see
them film from the 70s and I see a
cellular and you see a watery phone
uh-huh and you see I found things that
do not exist today I'm not even close to
the existing mm-hmm but the movie
theater experience like named me one
[ __ ] movie theater around there but I
go to the movies at midnight is there
one there is one and only likes one well
we were talking about that before you
got here first of all I'd be scared to
go to a movie and we had I'm thinking
about somebody's in the company and jerk
off and I used to love it last oh I love
Lee I grew up on a midnight movie every
[ __ ] Saturday there was a different
Rock movie or they play I want to see
Apocalypse at midnight at the midnight
showing you know an acid I always used
to hate that about I mean I hate it I
got mad in New York cuz in New York like
I take a 6 a.m. bus if I'm out at 4:00
why don't they have 24-hour movie
theaters I never especially now what
because the people go into asleep yeah a
12 o'clock movie that's an event yeah
I'm talking about a [ __ ] event at
midnight that's what I'm talking about
it's a rare thing that they do that now
they'll do that when a Marvel movie
opens I'll play it 24 hours a day
I remember seeing a I think it was the
first start Star Wars reboot they were
playing that from 7:00 p.m. until 3:00
or 4:00 in the morning
shut Theatre down for a couple hours and
then started up again 8:00 a.m. I mean
they'll do it when it's an event when
they know they can pack them in and
they're trying to get as many people
into the place as possible but you're
not gonna see yeah but the thing is like
when we were kids you didn't have
Netflix you didn't have Hulu or Amazon
Prime you couldn't pull up so much [ __ ]
just there you didn't have that
available to you so the theaters the you
know the theaters got to make money and
it costs money to staff it it cost money
to to light that place and keep it
running
so they're not gonna have people coming
in to do that
and they're not gonna give the
opportunity when it's only gonna be
three or four how much is a moving
[ __ ] ticket Laemmle and lammle ulema
is about 1213 dollars I think 13 [ __ ]
dollars they need that let's let you
keep the [ __ ] light and that's a
weird thing like they don't get much of
the of the ticket price they get all
their money from concessions most of the
tax but I was just gonna ask you guys
like what do you say how much blame do
you put cuz I know they of course it's a
business but five dollar candy can it be
three dollar candy and then and because
I saw what you're telling me is the
movie theater doesn't make a dime at the
door very small percentage make a very
small percent all go back to it all goes
back to the studio really yeah I think I
think probably 80 80 plus percent of
diagnosed studio yeah they make their
money off of concessions that's why it's
so ridiculously expensive that's why if
you got it the last time I took a woman
to see a movie popcorn sodas and a candy
bar cost me $30 it was [ __ ] ridiculous
I wonder Laemmle one time I got a sign
to go watch a movie from her podcast
this had to be ten years ago cuz I was
still 11 years ago I was still living in
Hollywood
alright and it was a Disney movie and
the girl who works at Rotten Tomatoes
whatever man he's great grace she had
the office downstairs she had it at the
time with Anna bata
mm-hm they were together at that time
whether the podcast yeah
and they asked me to be on about film
and they said go see this film I figured
I mean I think when I wipe till the
[ __ ] Laemmle mm-hmm
we dropped the half a yard exactly
because we got the sauce to chicken and
sauce on sandwiches [ __ ] huh
I remember going home that night and
sitting there going I'm not cheap yeah
by no means on my cheap but a half a
yard to go to the [ __ ] movie with
your wife there's a lot of doremi
and that was my quality I think that's
what skills because people now how many
of us have a home theater in her house
for not that much my I can't watch a
movie anymore Tommy I got wires
difficult I enjoyed Black Panther on the
and when I got on the plane and black
panther popped up on [ __ ] Delta I was
done like I had downloaded a bunch of
[ __ ] I'm like yeah I like to watch that
stuff look at this black to Hansel her
watch it you know on a plane I do not
get disturbed mm-hmm I could sit here
all [ __ ] day in the phone with
[ __ ] ring go to the movies with me
for three days I'll sit here my turns
not gonna leave there's no set to sit
here let's go to a movie and my world
ends
they gotta see me in 20 minutes the
casting yeah they did hell are you
available Friday for this whole day
everything comes in as soon as I step
foot into that [ __ ] Len Liang Liang
kitchen soon as I step foot in there the
[ __ ] thing goes off yeah so what
happens is even if I don't answer the
phone my mind is thinking why is Lee
calling me twice yeah
why is Rick calling me four times
there's somebody get hit by a car now I
actually get up to go pee and there goes
the [ __ ] movie that you can't do that
goes the movie that when I go to a movie
theater
I usually go at the time when I realize
okay have I booked anything for tomorrow
do I got some extra work tomorrow do I
have something else that I can do that
I'm gonna I'm not gonna have to be I'm
not gonna be I'm not gonna be beholden
to the phone where it's like no I gotta
check it and I got a chicken I got a
chicken because I've done that and it
[ __ ] up the movie watching experience
you know you know and I I don't want to
be the guy that's checking his phone in
the [ __ ] theater because I hate that
guy I don't want to do that you know but
it does take you out of the movie
watching experience it sued correct if I
when I first started comedy I started
County at the broker in a mold that's
not why I started I started the demo
Callie works but the broker did copy and
the pro kleh was very they were cool as
[ __ ] yeah this is I'm talking ninety-one
I'm okay
it was the known hotspot on Wednesdays
it was called like professional whatever
they gave away shrimp so you had every
[ __ ] mama local yeah yeah you know
when you give everybody had Cologne on
yeah her booze looking to meet and
mingle it was a [ __ ] hysterical scene
but the food was delicious and I did
comedy there on Tuesdays Tuesday's
mistake night and then calmly
monday was Monday Night Football and
they'd have [ __ ] finger food Lee you
go crazy they had little hot dogs and
[ __ ] and shrimp yeah they always had
shrimp
what are they have Trump from Colorado I
have no idea that [ __ ] in I used to eat
it [ __ ] blood and he beat them you could
do it back then Mel doesn't end on the
first Sunday of every month with the
seafood or you could eaten and they have
a salmon that was out that he went and
took pieces of you have no idea it was
heaven but I never forget I went to the
buffet one time and then the juices
weren't included and they banged me $7 a
glass with fresh-squeezed orange juice
I'm over there drinking army just like I
got the him I drank my 20 glasses and I
was down like a buck for the [ __ ] you
know just in juice just didn't [ __ ]
believe it lose madam you have a [ __ ]
honor for Yas like [ __ ] juice that's
how much juice I used to drink is me now
a juice I drank I figured that got rid
of the cocaine the vitamin C stuff but
that my point being on Sunday night was
movie night yeah at the place at the bar
and they would play two old movies my
two Clint Eastwood to Charles Bronson to
car you know something of a theme yeah
and they would charge five bucks to get
in and that's where they went wrong and
free bit something like finger food
yeah and people go in their [ __ ]
pajamas and sit in a booth yeah and
watch movies on Sunday and I always
figured out how the [ __ ] they got away
with a thieves because nobody's
reporting it you know if you're doing it
under the radar and nobody knows and
they can't say anything but all it takes
is one person to go to call in and say
you know what this company is charging
for this let's say let's say some
[ __ ] goes in there and he he he
throws something on a waitress she
rejects him now his attitude is I'm
gonna call up the studio or I'm gonna
call up some legal people and say hey
they are showing movies and I know you
guys aren't getting the cut out of that
so it's rat [ __ ] you know it's them
we're adding somebody out there just
doing that you know now the purpose of
variable with you is to make money
ya know 1995 1985 I lived in San
Francisco and on the northern end of
Haight Ashbury
two blocks away from the park was a
movie theater that you went into had
couches yeah all right then I basically
had three rows three four rows of
couches all different couches yeah they
went into a flea market just what
couches yes the place probably seeded I
don't know 90/60 you know - perfect
you know each couch maybe four people
can sit yeah and they opened up a little
oven and they had a matinee they had
homemade chocolate chip cookies you see
the cousins blowing out of the tray
uh-huh and people would put them in the
oven and then would take them out and
serve and they also would have you know
those bars of butter mm-hmm they would
have the bar of butter and they would
put real butter on the [ __ ] popcorn I
mean this was just superb yeah and they
had long and they had little footstools
mm-hmm if you wanted to put a footstool
up you could sit there I forget what it
costs to get it but I remember sitting
there going how do they make money here
you know I want to see masks that we
share and Rock Eric Stults and yeah yeah
yeah what does he mast and that was
blown the [ __ ] away now until this day
that would be a dream for me to move to
some small town and open up a small
movie theater that just plays old films
you know who wouldn't have to pay a
victor well you know there's not much
that's why it's like they have dollar
theaters and stuff still great older
movies yeah they're gonna put out the
dollar they're gonna put out those cheap
movies because there's not a lot of them
but it doesn't cost them much except to
get the film to you and now they can do
it digitally so it's it's much easier
now you project it whatever you make on
charging people to get in that goes to
the studio that has to go to this to
that dollar to dollar that dollar that
$2 I always make my money from making
fresh pizzas exactly shrimp cocktails
and now a lot of these places are
serving liquor now salute they got it
they got it in their head they got the
right thing the ArcLight
there's a theater in in Pasadena and
West LA I pick great they'll have
couches they'll have these big lazy boy
recliner what's I I pick it's it's just
a fancy they have it on the floor I want
my dad
they have regular like reclining seats
but then in the back where the better
seats are they have they give you a
nickel a nice little blanket and they
have weight or service in the theater
so you know you just go sit straight
down call them they bring the M&Ms in
like a little martini glass I've seen
waiter service mm-hmm in 1990 a
deterrent yeah I don't they we're
already ahead of the [ __ ] game in 98
they had a movie theater that had weight
waiters waitresses I think they brought
your beer I'm I don't want to say that
for sure
yeah I'm not saying that for sure but
yeah yeah once your eyes are doors that
beam off a blow yeah that that's the
thing that brought people in there
because look people people still love
the movie watching experience going out
because now you're committed to
something you gotta you got to make the
effort to get out of your house look
when you're sitting at your house and
you're watching a movie you got your kid
there you got your wife doing you know
maybe she's balancing the checkbook
maybe maybe she's talking about what you
guys are gonna do for the next day she's
preparing something in the kitchen you
got a million [ __ ] fall phone calls
coming in we got the internet that's you
know you're on your phone checking to
see if there's it somebody sent
something to you when you're in a movie
theater it's less likely for any of that
to happen and if you're goofy you can
really tell yourself you know what I'm
going to see a movie I'm not [ __ ]
around with anything when I go I turn my
phone almost completely off I don't want
to deal with it I don't want to I don't
want to think about it I just want to
watch that movie for two [ __ ] hours I
mean it's on until the movie starts and
as soon as it's finished
it's on again but while the movie is on
I'm watching this [ __ ] I'm dedicated
especially if it's something that I've
seen that I love or it's a director that
I do like or or or an actor doing
something but that the problem is that
nowadays it's like I find myself going
to movies just because hey you know I
got the past I might as well just go see
this way yeah I'm bored out of my mind
no nothing comes true to you anymore
nothing is it's so it's all so hard
you'll even though and you could you
know what I was talking to you I was
thinking about like your ideal movie
theater experience would be I don't even
want to wait it I know my own [ __ ]
food ya know I don't I don't understand
I don't even bring food I
food movie theaters I like I like to get
pizza at a movie theater
yeah like slices of pizza like - I'll
get a hope I like a good good New York
style pie at a pizza in yeah I'd like
the reclining chair oh yeah table next
to me and the guy 4 feet away from me
see that's okay I'll pay Johnny for that
you see I'll pay the 20 for that
no absolutely you know I don't want to
weigh that yeah you know what yeah if he
wants to wait on me [ __ ] it but no it
does it does get a little bit Barlet for
everyone else because they see the
waiter walking in they talk a little bit
that like that's like that's the whole
point when you're like oh I'm not
watching this at home because I have
distractions and it it like it hurts my
feelings almost when people come to
movies and talk well I'm like I can't
stand it you know no I can't I can't
when they're having a full-fledged good
conversation or somebody picks up their
phone and has a conversation get the
[ __ ] out of there or if you know the
Mexicans are the worst because they'll
they'll come in there with their kids
it'll be Deadpool you'll be watching
something ridiculously we're just
ridiculous to have a child in it'll be
11 o'clock at night and they'll have
their [ __ ] kids in there and I'm just
sitting there like my god my people are
[ __ ] up but this is the kind of like
like I'll go out of my way like I'll
never see a blockbuster film on a Friday
or Saturday or even a Sunday I'll go
Monday when I know that there's nobody
gonna be there and there's no chance of
me really getting on loud audition or
getting called for any [ __ ] I like
to go to the 10:30 or 11:00 a.m. knock
that [ __ ] out by 1:00 and now I got my
whole day ahead of me too
plus it helps me wake up in the morning
you know it's a good thing to start the
day with a movie but there's gonna be
fewer people in there which is great
that's a sad aspect of my life it is
it's a sad aspect of my life that the
biggest movie I've seen the last six
months Black Panther and I saw it on the
plane and that the movie theater
experience has been gone from me for
close to 20 years ya know because I
enjoyed movies I still
when to move I still gonna see payback
mm-hmm with Mel Gibson Ralphie May and
I'm Jody 30 good bunch of us went to see
payback yeah so it's been probably maybe
15 years I felt like it wasn't going to
the movies anymore I felt like I was
getting beat well you know I don't love
going to the movies when it's a crowd we
you me I think I think Ari
Edwin and all right to see the movie
about Clint Eastwood with the Chinese
family and we saw that but we also saw
Godfather we saw we saw Godfather too we
saw it at there at the ArcLight we might
have been in the Cinerama Dome and it
was great it was [ __ ] fantastic but
it was a bunch of friends reliving this
great film watching experience because
up until that point I don't think I'd
ever seen the Godfather true in a
theater I think I saw it for the first
time in a theater with you guys I had
seen it on TV had seen it on broadcast
but also I'd seen it on DVD but seeing
it with you guys was on a whole other
level because you got that camaraderie
there were sitting there were laughing
we're having a good time were screaming
out you know and and we're reliving
something that that all of us had
experienced at one point or another in
our lives but now we're together doing
it but you're right like the going to
the movies by yourself thing that's hard
now what's hard I love it because I
don't see that's the time I'm not gonna
dump a friend if they if they don't talk
during a movie if they're if they do
that I'm not gonna go see a movie with
them well that's the thing yeah you're
not going to and it becomes very
difficult to find those friends that are
not going to talk during a movie that
are not going to check either I'll be
honest with you between you and then I'd
rather go to movies by myself I'm not
gonna lie anything I've always been a
movie cuz I don't like drama
yeah I don't want to get you out if I
tell you getting ready 11 o'clock cuz we
gotta go for Chinese ballet on 20 cuz
the movie starts at the corner of 12 I
already told the Chinese guy yesterday I
was going be having 15 to be ready for
me like it was an event like I was
telling Lee you know I never got to see
this
but what I heard this mm-hmm I always
the commercial in class intelligent at
the University of Colorado some intro
whatever class and they were talking
about how in the 60s and 50s yeah what a
new car would get out mhm
would be released it they'd say the new
Chevrolet comes out September 1st yeah
that car was in the showroom August 1st
with a blanket on top and everyday
people would walk up just to take a peek
under the blanket and see if they can
look under the sheet whatever the [ __ ]
you want to call it that was over the
car
you know it created a sense it created a
different feeling in you yeah that's
what I still remember being a little boy
and watching the trailer for the French
Connection mm-hmm and like I couldn't
wait for that [ __ ] movie to come out
you know I could judge a movie now today
for my a trailer yeah I could it doesn't
take a genius I know you could you could
see that this is the gold of this movie
you could tell yeah so like I said to
you I felt beat by the movies when I
went that time my wife it was like two
or three times I went to the movies and
I went home and said that was a great
movie but why did I do this a month like
I had to pay to park walk a mile yeah
like I did all this [ __ ] to go to this
[ __ ] movie that was so [ __ ]
expensive for that I could have been
helicopter didn't was I spent yeah I
could have been helicopter in and again
I'm not talking about being cheap and
it's the same across the board listen
man when it comes to comedy I got a
greedy [ __ ] agents and they will call
me sometimes and go this is the contract
I go why is it ticket $36 yeah I don't
go volume and I don't know what blue cop
I'm a blue column in town yeah a movie
theater used to be you went to a comedy
club of the movie was sold out mm-hmm
what's a [ __ ] movie now okay I get it
but when they come to me with these
deals I tell them listen keep it at 25
bucks
now that's two tickets fifty bucks
that's the general [ __ ] to go up hey you
know we get robbed at
every level in this country now whether
it's a baseball game whether it's a
[ __ ] Laker game you got a light you
can't afford a leg again no you know
what most people can't afford to fly
anymore
come look a plane ticket sometimes
you're like how you know if if if I was
a baseline comic right now yeah I'd be
starving
I'd be starving I'm telling you right
now please what do they pay a baseline
time with 12 to 1500 to win maybe you
know plane ticket
no no plane ticket no no you got a high
like a [ __ ] like I'm a Mook
yeah I can you know you gotta fly like
it through one of those mud sores that
you sit in the back with luggage and
yeah you know you have no that's the
only way you make a profit yes to sell
t-shirts and CDs yourself yeah do and
now you gotta put it on the plane too so
now you gotta pay the frame on the frame
all no no it's it's uh it's uh it's it's
amazing what it takes to make a living
uh-huh but it's also amazing of what
these people charge you from your
services anymore you know I compare
ticket prices all the time when I fly
huh and even like JetBlue mint its if I
take a flight idea before if I buy a
ticket a year before an American to
Kennedy even with my platinum [ __ ]
status yeah I won't get an upgrade like
I've never gotten upgrade to New York or
Chicago I figure out a way all the time
to get have to take it off on JetBlue
and I have the club pay for the other
half yeah and I take that one with the
bet on the way back I fly there like a
[ __ ] my MOOC in the straight seat and
on Sunday I don't want no drama
yeah when I go through the airport on
Sunday have already gone through five
shows I've talked to a [ __ ] 800
people and I'm [ __ ] done I can't want
to see nobody I don't explain myself
come on do nothing
yeah but it's it's weird like once the
movie industry did it to me boom
well the movie industry did it because
they were losing they were losing what's
cable hit and and not only did cable hit
now you could they were getting money
out of they were getting money out of
repeats of movies but
and they started they started doing the
original content Netflix Hulu Amazon red
you know YouTube red they all have their
own original contact and because of that
people aren't going to movies like they
used to
they'll go to a big they'll go to
they'll go to something like Avengers
the New Avengers film a new Marvel film
it's gonna make money no matter what
Black Panther was gonna be huge no
matter what but you have to spend each
one of those each one of those movies
cost about 150 to 300 million to make
now you have to make I have to make
about 600 million to a billion dollars
just to break even and I mean that's
according to their their [ __ ] their
accounting it can't possibly be right
but they [ __ ] themselves by creating
all these other avenues because it made
it impossible for for movies to sustain
themselves you can't go to a [ __ ]
theater because the theaters gonna lose
money if I go into a movie theater and
I'm using movie pass so I'm getting my
movie for [ __ ] two dollars probably
the number of movies that I go see a
month I do not buy [ __ ] when I'm there
so a guy like me I make them no money I
make them no money whatsoever I might
sneak it a Snickers bar in with me so
now I'm actually [ __ ] them a little
bit more but this is the way it goes I
mean once television came in radio went
out it's it's technology advances to a
point where whatever existed before
slowly starts to die movie theaters
movie theaters are still probably the
most affordable going out kind of thing
that you can do because if you think
movie theaters are bad try to get a
ticket to go see a play at the Pantages
that [ __ ] going to see whatever show
wicked or or Hamilton or any of that a
single tickets gonna cost you 75 to $100
for that probably more more yeah more
and that's that's like you're gonna take
you're gonna take a date out for that
now don't leave out 50 you know I'm here
to go to yang
Stadium yeah getting robbed I heard said
getting robbed but you just can't
believe Timmy told me Joe I mean I've
had so many friends tell me that they
went the Yankee Stadium when they they
left there feeling like what the [ __ ]
just happened
I mean [ __ ] right there red alone twenty
to forty dollars to park fifty fifty to
par fifty yeah I don't know what Dodger
Stadium is I don't know what a Angel
Stadium is but it's gonna be 40 to 50
bucks right there I know the football
stadium is expensive
whatever they play football at yeah well
owned by USC when they first started we
finally picked it with a hundred bucks
to park no I mean who knows if it's
still that but yeah but I want to first
starter but that's a it's it's a college
stadium but it's gonna be right over by
LAX yeah so that yeah you're not gonna
be able to fly in on Sundays anymore but
they're figuring your ball season we can
get this out of the people if we can get
this out of them and they're gonna pay
then let's charge it you know they have
no scruples in that they got they got no
they've got no result I'm kind of
working I'll get the schedule and I'm
not flying in the home game well no well
it's gonna be the Rams in the charger so
it's every Sunday for four months and
there's no public transportation in LA
so you're [ __ ] either way that's why
that's why you know but but with that
comes different opportunities now it's
like now you got all these guys they got
a million [ __ ] actors as basically
basically taxi drivers now ubering
all goddamn night long so they can I
don't know in a lot of honey that's
working I mean either I don't know many
people who are working it's okay they
can't for superior dollars mm-hmm I
didn't know that I didn't I didn't find
that out they canceled [ __ ] the mick
they can't to cancel 99 NBC picked up
they cancelled a lot of show they
canceled a lot that made me [ __ ] and say
what where they gonna go with that yeah
yeah where they go aren't they remaking
a lot of shows like them Roseanne is
going into the second season feelin
great yeah Roseanne Will and Grace
there's another one that they're
rebooting I think I can't remember
but and you know and that's gonna use
actors as well but it's like they're not
as hard as it has been to make a living
as a comic and as an actor in past years
it's damn near impossible to bend out
it's incredibly I mean I don't know like
I'm not working at all I'm going out for
extra work background work I'm
collecting unemployment and I'm trying
to hustle up whatever the [ __ ] I can you
know everybody's chasing the same thing
have to and in the commercial business
right now it's it's changed completely
I got the lowdown last week it's changed
completely
remember hearing these stories where you
could book a commercial maybe two
commercials and you'd be set for the
year separately that [ __ ] will never
happen again
yeah yeah you need to you need to book
four or five commercials in a year and
I'm having a hard enough time booking
one you know what I got to say I had one
commercial that changed my life
did that much money and I was dumb I
thought it was gonna be like this I
didn't know he don't dumb and full of
[ __ ] and I took that money and it was
overwhelming the amount of money they
paid yeah for a Taco Bell commercial and
I was overwhelming yeah and I booked two
other ones at the time they were duds
table they would dogs with fleas seven
grand thirteen grand yeah for the most
of most person you'd say Joey you should
be grateful to getting seven grand not
when you made 80 grand and four [ __ ]
money now she's on the Taco Bell
commercial 80 grand in four [ __ ]
months in 1997 you know my first
commercial was 2003 2004 over a year and
a half spanned about 28,000 rich I
thought that was great that was your
first couple that was my first
commercial and I didn't book another
Union commercial for ten years all I
would book was non-union at anywhere
between 300 and 1500 a pop I got lucky
on one that hit me five grand and then
they renegotiated it for another
five grand a year later but this is why
this is why I was always too afraid to
just quit and and to quit teaching and
then just throw myself full-hearted into
that [ __ ] because I thought well if I'm
gonna only be depending on I'm acting
then I gotta stay in LA I can't even go
on the road so I'm gonna how the [ __ ] am
I gonna live off of a twenty dollar
spots here and there was the scariest
thing which is what I'm doing now it's a
very tough Oh tough transition yeah it's
a very very tough transition I am very
fortunate that all those years all I
give I give them thanks yeah every day I
listen I thank the commies so I think
the improbable I think all that but I
give thanks to those young Mexicans they
have had all those rooms and I was from
2000 from 1998 to 2007 they kept me in
cocaine special and you know donuts she
wake Mexican food every height every
night wing every night it was crazy five
nights a week wile coyote half a Latina
we have a Martinez and Maryland nudists
coupe of every new latin room that has
open it and it was something lee that i
would give my right hand for today every
night we went somewhere la puente Long
Beach Visalia [ __ ] mentor every comic
we you knew had a [ __ ] Wednesday that
paid fifty [ __ ] bucks
we played bars we played past omniversal
City mm-hmm any anything all those
places that passed taco what's that on
the five which press on the [ __ ] taco
taco yeah I don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody says when I got an assignment to
go out and I'm asking taco whether it
was $50 $75 and thirty I was happy
because I was getting to [ __ ] talk on
the way home Walter Marino you were
eating cheap you were eating cheap leave
you that's the way it is people don't
even know it's like when I when I first
got to the comedy store I was sitting
out I was
now they're on the port with the other
idiots and we had to go in on Saturday
night to sign up for the spot then we
had to come back Sunday morning it at
like 11:00 noon maybe we had to draw
tickets out of out of out of a bucket
then we had seven hours to just [ __ ]
around because the open mic didn't start
until seven o'clock so we would go over
to McDonald's over there on over there
by by by Laurel Canyon yeah and you're
next up Boyle oh yeah and we would each
get about five 39 cent cheeseburgers and
we would take those down and we were we
were eating shitty but we were young and
we have we were full alive but we had
dreams and we were talking about what we
were gonna do and then some of us
started working at The Comedy Store then
that's when she was paying as $25 I'm
not shift yeah it was [ __ ] yeah that
shift could go anywhere from three hours
to the [ __ ] yeah two to three the more
than picking up table yeah twenty-five
hours that's still that Mexican scene I
remember in 2000 so yeah when it first
dried up that Mexican cuz I felt it in
my eye
2008 yeah was when something happened in
California in all those bars that were
doomed commies that's it no the writers
strike pretty much it was 2008 however
the writers strike was when I go wow why
am I so broke yeah I remember looking
going look
I had a notebook with all the 40s and
thirty-five 50s and let me tell you some
at the end little weak believing that
all those $50 is 75 our spots used to
head up don't $40 date all that up some
nights you did three him you did a 75 a
50 and a four you were running bomb spot
spot spot
it was Darin Carter was in the mix
there's so many people in the mix I'm
sorry about that today that doesn't
exist doesn't exist in sad and kids
don't hustle no no you were just walk
into a bar and go
we wanted to comedy here how much you
gonna pay us three hundred three hundred
we could work with
that's a headliner that's a feature I
could pay myself are okay you are you
had a ball bar would pay off a bar would
pay you you wanna run the thing but you
would have to pay the condom so you want
to be
you're not gonna get your comics so you
gotta be good for the comics you got him
yeah you gotta negotiate drink tickets
for the comics and you gotta have some
type of food out yeah that's that's what
matters the food and we would drive to
[ __ ] oh my god yeah you know you're
gonna get a [ __ ] burrito with french
fries and he wasn't gonna eat his I'll
trade you drink tickets for your meal
okay you know it was just a camaraderie
type of thing you guys ever run a room I
ran two rooms did you run in Iran Iran a
room out there with Zhivago out in West
Covina it was a Mexican restaurant and
we had a couple of good shows but we
couldn't sustain it and then I had the
sapphire in Alhambra on Main Street and
I think I had you out there a few times
I mean I love the people Marilyn that's
where Martin Moreno got into a fistfight
yeah with the guy I was in it was a
great little place was just a lounge it
was just it they'll all weird places
like lounges what was the one off on
Monday nights that the bars like you
think Sinatra was there the guy puts out
appetizers and there was at that spot
over there I'm fountain and he got off
off the fado even know that was a great
little spot on one there was so many
great little time they had a Chinese
restaurant that there was no white
people in there and one of those donut
spots yeah that will [ __ ]
mind-blowing a mind-blowing well one of
the sad things was that you knew if you
were gonna make any kind of real money
which was like $50 or more you couldn't
be in LA yeah yeah you had to go to
Torrance you had to go to cities yeah
up north had a thousand gigs yeah you
were going up north every [ __ ] night
yeah two nights a week letting our last
kids over there but not like a not a lot
Lancaster Lancaster yeah Lancaster I had
two gigs all this [ __ ] off the 170 up
there there was a bunch of scary gigs on
that [ __ ] up there there has to be a
Wednesday night Latin night about 45
minutes from here and that served your
food that all that [ __ ] that [ __ ] went
away for the comics they were bars would
pay for anything do you think like
younger comics are a little bit more
responsible because I just held my first
show and I'm not gonna throw anyone
under the bus but one of the comics who
we booked didn't show up so that's all
happened yeah but how do you if you're
gonna have a show like it must be that's
a little you gotta head out when we were
doing it there were always enough comics
hanging around that we could we could
fit somebody in there always somebody
would go in yeah but then how do you how
do you only tell one person they got a
spot I ran into that too how do you tell
one person if eight people are there you
know what if he wants to do it bad
enough he will take that spot that's the
thing we we performed in front of two or
three people at a time we've performed
when when there was no microphone when
the light didn't work for the real stage
you didn't give a [ __ ] you just did the
[ __ ] you went out there and you told
your jokes or you made [ __ ] up while you
were standing there 100 I would I meant
to what I meant to say was like if let's
say you and Joey and Darren and card
over here and I had one spot to give
puts me in kind of a weird position I'll
give one of us no I understand I got
that first you don't put it on your mind
this is think I got no time we
understand here okay there's people that
just show up and they can't do that
either
yeah that's disrespectful you just can't
show up either oh I didn't know he
didn't tell me yeah really
wow this is great no I don't take that
[ __ ] you got a lot of [ __ ] I shop
all the time in Bret I used to run into
that all the time just happened in
Ontario when I was there yeah
people just sure it was happening and
started ordering drinks and ordering
food get the [ __ ] out of my [ __ ]
green room yeah get the [ __ ] out of here
don't be ordering food yet nobody knows
you yeah somebody knows you nobody knows
you get the [ __ ] outta you you got a
really cool guy yeah you gotta come back
so you got really cool people and then
you got people that just time that they
don't like I've always said going where
you don't belong you don't go we don't
bore you didn't invite you and you don't
know don't go well I'm here to support
go support yourself go support the flag
go [ __ ] go marches something like
that
where's Tony Bennett guns that's funny
man that's funny I want to congratulate
Danny and Tyra to get married this
weekend congratulations Nick Lucas Josh
brought I was a Lewisville NC ajahn
Petoskey it's not Nathaniel urban city
chick
Matthew RR Kelly that's it that's all
you got sorry but no problem I said June
4th with tape in the Netflix special
tickets a gun and then June 17th or some
of my Colusa casino I don't know if you
want to come come on out let's [ __ ]
jump up and down a little bit and have a
[ __ ] good time the topic of the
podcast originally before we went off on
the [ __ ] set Tanzania how was revenge
and plain-out revenge movies yeah the
first year first one I ever seen was
death death wish that was the first one
it was the classic it's the movie
theater you know and then you look at
man on fire which is another one you
know I have always been a big fan of
revenge movies somebody even the movie
revenge
yeah with kill madeleine stowe at a most
gorgeous all tremendous damn what a
[ __ ] fun right yeah what a great [ __ ]
yeah the revenge is a little tough a
little tough if you don't like women
getting beat up it's a hard one to watch
but it's it's it's pretty weird you know
what about like movies that have revenge
and then you've said revenge the two I
kept thinking about were pulp fiction
when the guy when they like get out of
the sex dungeon and then this might be a
little bit too new for you Joe but
office space
seeing Milton burn that place down
basically a movie it's a good movie it's
a good movie I've never not liked the
office space revenge is a kind of it
revenge's is this real thing because
every you know we for the most part we
live our lives taking [ __ ] just I mean
whether it's your job whether it's a
supervisor whether it's your wife or
your husband somebody is giving you [ __ ]
that you can't deal with a movie that
the guy [ __ ] snaps
Michael Douglas falling down oh my god
that's one of my all-time
isn't that the great it's like
everything everything kicking his ass
and he was like no I'm not gonna take
this [ __ ] away is that you on the one
open between where the 101 and the five
and the 110 all meet that's where I
would smell that's that's well [ __ ] yeah
that's why I would snap that's why I
don't like the dry
people there you go there you go I tell
you if there's a movie about a guy that
nobody remembers called what falling
down falling Lee have you seen it no I
married her it's great and it's it's
Michael Douglas with this crew-cut
hairdo he's just watch this he plays
this [ __ ] white nerd with glasses on
his wife won't let him see the kid yeah
it's a [ __ ] catastrophe you know he's
going through a divorce when I watched
that movie I was going through see with
me that came out late I must have been
about 97 I think when I came out I've
been believing they're going boy they
know exactly have a [ __ ] I feel yeah
that's 9390 told you Wow okay then I was
just getting divorced I was going
through everything I was broke I was
living with alko LOL his [ __ ] house
in Arvada Colorado you know I was living
in a bedroom yeah wife would call me
would page me ten times a day to ask me
about her husband he was a horrible
situation I was it I couldn't see my kid
I had no money I was living off the
advance I got from Douglas Toyota and I
remember in the afternoons I would go to
work her over here and if there's
nothing going on you sneak out for lunch
but you go to the mall and steal a car
go to the mall eat Chinese food and go
to a movie that's what I do
I saw 20 movies yeah this is you know I
would go see the getaway and all those
Malloy yeah yeah but I went to see that
[ __ ] war with Michael Douglas thing
you said and I'll never forget that
movie theater walking out there going
they [ __ ] nailed it I got head yeah
how I felt like his Cobb no no like he
just got of his car
everything on it you know what it is
he's it's the middle of the summer he's
in that underpass that you go to get
onto the 101 where you just got off the
110 there's an underpass maybe it's to
take you to the one town I don't
remember but you're sitting there and he
has this kid looking at him from the
backseat of another car his air
conditioner doesn't work he's just
[ __ ] pissed off wet he's sweating his
ass off he's been fired from his job
he's just in a bad [ __ ] mental place
and he said we'll divorce yeah that I
was gold during the time
I could just I was feeling [ __ ] a
[ __ ] and that movie theater at that
time and he walks out of his car and he
just walks away from he's just trying to
get to Venice and then Lee something
that couldn't happen happen they as he's
walking in the neighborhood they try to
muggles oh no he beats the [ __ ] on the
one night he yells you want the bag and
they both run away I'll never forget
that
like he's not having a bat and the even
thousand guys I'm having a really bad
day yeah don't make me [ __ ] it in there
[ __ ] them with him
what about changing lanes change lanes
with Affleck and what sounds like a
similar movie it's different in that
yeah you have you seen change wings oh
it's um Samuel Jackson is a guy who's uh
he's been busting his ass to get a loan
for a house and he gets in a car
accident with Ben Affleck in Ben
Africa's going to a business meeting but
Ben Affleck doesn't have the time to
help him for them to fill out the the
work so that they could they can get
this accident taken care of Sam
Jackson's car will run he didn't see
through the bank at a certain time and
Affleck leaves them there
a flicks is how it's not my problem you
know but Jackson gets the paperwork that
Ben Africa needs for later on it's a
pretty good movie it's a pretty good
movie but I'll tell you right now ain't
no falling down falling down is on all
of the level dad's on the whole well but
it's like it's it's weird because
Michael Douglas has this stature you
know I mean Michael Douglas was the
white guy of that generation you know he
was Gordon Gekko he was the great white
hunter he was the great adventurer but
now he's this guy who who did everything
by the book and got [ __ ] anyway and I
think that's the part that makes it
resonate with people the most was like
I'm just trying to be a good guy I did
everything you were told you told me to
do and now I don't have a job I don't
have a home my [ __ ] give my kid my
wife won't let me see my kid what where
the [ __ ] am I supposed to you know get
this right that taps into a psyche
especially of of American men who who
find themselves losing out
how about ours when I walked out a movie
thing I felt better than I did yeah
because I knew that other people were
ready to snap yeah it's a horrible
feeling when no the cards are going your
way yeah every day something else
tumbles yeah that's a horrible feeling
oh it's absolutely you know what itself
created some time but you created
somewhere oh yeah
you left a missing peg some way you left
something and then because man for years
it would like I strum him to get in the
coffin Comedy Works like getting
momentum and calmly like getting
momentum like people started hiring me
and almost I got a call in there I'm
banned from the Comedy Works for sexual
harassment only what the [ __ ] they
talking about yeah I'm the manager said
he saw you grabbing her ass whatever
like that type of [ __ ] like I was you
know every day was that was part of many
things yeah at that time I don't mean I
can't even remember I got was getting I
bounced a check my wife found that she
took me to court I mean it was just that
every day was something else and that
was the main that was the main anger but
it was me not seeing my child she would
hold the child over me that's a big
anger that's a big [ __ ] you that's a big
yeah you know and then that's a big [ __ ]
you to overcome sometimes when they're
playing games or the kinloch I I saw the
writing on the wall thank God yeah I
feel very bad today and if I could
apologize to anybody I would but I knew
I wasn't gonna get the raise that girl
it didn't take a genius from the
beginning I got the warning side so when
I went to see that movie it kind of
cleared the air for me a little bit
sometimes a movie will do that yeah and
sometimes a movie is as far-fetched as
this seems sometimes you're watching
moving you really really a relatable
tell you you don't move there felt
relatable to I thought why I always
thought I was gonna be the catcher a
major-league Tom Berenger crap that's
the type of comic I thought I was gonna
be when I first saw that Morag okay I
get it now
I'm gonna be one of those comics that
called plays in whorehouses and [ __ ]
dirty bars and I'm never gonna be on TV
so it really doesn't matter yeah but
when I saw that movie like he was like
when he goes to dinner and they go what
are you gonna pay a lot of money and he
goes no I make the league minimum yeah
that ball though that whole thing felt
like me well this time you go to a movie
and you relate to that like for me my
movie experience growing up was it was
to get away from the noise at the bar my
mother with a book making the mother
would sports-betting the drugs and all
that [ __ ] it would take me away as a
child yeah I can name on one hand the
movies I saw at the Union City cinema
mm-hmm and your heart would stop Tony I
remember rocky there mm-hm and the
audience on their feet cheering the
whole movie theater yeah at the end of
it during the fight
oh Jesus Yellin rocky rocky rocky rocky
the whole move it easily I saw The
Exorcist their iced remember seeing the
long as you're dead all of us on our
feet yelling mean machine made machine
the main machine you know I still
remember scene and the dragon there and
I still remember seeing the Chinese
connection there and the Chinese
connection they actually had an 11
o'clock viewing yeah you didn't get out
of the movie through the toe one my
mother would let me go as like an 8 year
old because it was on 48th Street the
only thing that was on 29th we walk home
I'm burning my head was straight shot
and my mother could call the movie Thea
you know I'm saying and check out me
there that's how cool it was your mother
to call the movie theater there wasn't
there was a freedom to that there was a
magic that that doesn't exist now
because I mean she it was just as
dangerous back then and this see just
one aware of it there was no [ __ ]
nothing now the seats slide like that's
it that's all you had it was like on the
back the seat slided you didn't worry
about comfort I didn't care about a
waitress it was just a general attitude
of the movies how exciting everybody was
yeah when I go to a movie now
well I have the other day I went to eat
over at the greenhouse over in
Lancashire miles across the street from
the Laemmle they got a ten pooch on
[ __ ] tap got a rock your world over
there
cherry he [ __ ] they got everything
over there but I sit there and I see
people going to the movie theater and
then that movie fans right now it's more
to stand on line it's something else
yeah they didn't go that it's I don't
know it feels different I haven't yet
the one that I sat there and actually
watched them on that one I don't know
what movie it was you know over there
they always have these you know
intelligent Laemmle and [ __ ] you know
and they're sitting there and I'm
watching these people on line I'm
telling myself these have these people
aren't even here to watch this movie
they wanna be on that line yeah they're
not film buffs let me tell you something
bro I remember vividly yeah one of the
greatest days of my life honestly like
if I look like this is how how much of a
[ __ ] degenerate I am one of the
biggest best days of my life was you
wouldn't have to drive when you were in
a halfway house do you think that stuff
yeah I had a car park three blocks away
and I'm gonna Park it on the trees and
bushes and I would walk one way and then
walk two blocks and cross the street and
go behind a building and my car was
there yeah and I still remember going to
see [ __ ] good father like I had a
pager yeah I'm in the halfway house now
when I got the prison the prison
librarian who gave me the book one day
oh yeah he does you read this book read
this book I was blown the [ __ ] away and
then two weeks later in my prison black
on white TV
Henry Hill was on 20/20 mmm-hmm and he
told all these crazy [ __ ] stories I'm
like Jesus Christ yeah so I was reaiiy
read the book already wise guy and here
he was this was way this was a year
before the movie came when I wasn't when
I was in prison this was a year before
the VariCam huh
they were just trying to hype it up a
little bit like a
before that you know they sold the book
and I was a halfway house from
Goodfellas premiering on a Friday and
dog and in those days you have a give
them a phone number where you were gonna
go phone I leave there okay so where you
headed up a head of police I ass house
666 Coldwater Boulevard what's his phone
number I'll write your phone number how
long it's gonna take me to get there I'm
gonna take the limo three bus I'll be
there in 40 minutes and how long we stay
there two and you have to call when you
leave so they would have to verify all
this information I found the loophole
they gave a page in them you have to
hide your pagers on them no no no keep
it in my pocket and because I told him
they needed it for work and I had to
travel for work so I went back to court
got a pass to drive and I was allowed to
drive cars at work do you follow me yeah
I paid a lot of attorney to do all this
[ __ ] because I wanted to get my ass
covered there's no way I'm not gonna
drive yeah what a man if I had Lewis and
Clark on the wall oh [ __ ] you so I would
hide cause and I would never forget one
then I was excited like I woke up but
you know when you open your eyes
yeah like oh [ __ ] it's good fella late
today and I stood over the Chinese
restaurant I went to how do I hate like
with the napkin yeah like I was going
and I remember smoking like I didn't
give a [ __ ] yeah if they give me a piss
test so beer I'm not gonna go see
Goodfellas and not be high and when they
gave that mailman of beating my brother
was a family yeah that's how I might run
he was a man aware that I was Howard I
was Howlin and that Sunday I had to go
to my wife's family's house for dinner
and they had the priest over and the
priest said anybody see the movie
Goodfellas oh no [ __ ] I swear to god
father Tom was his name and I me and him
just started dropping knowledge he was
loving it he was loving us this is a
little chubby priests gone when he put
his head in a pizza I loved it when they
put his head in the pizza thing you know
I'll give you like that every movie I
went to to me was an event whether it
was the the black dragon the movie the
Shogun of Harlem whatever that was
called or office and gentleman I psyched
myself up for movies yeah dude I had
that time that still you know what I
have it now but I don't have it with new
releases it's it's it's very rare that I
have it with a new release but you're
still stuck on the old films I'm stuck
on the old films because every once in a
while you see you find [ __ ] gold and
I'm not I'm and I'm like you I don't
want to sound like an old man who just
it's stuck in the past because the
majority is [ __ ] that I really love is
from way before I was watching movies
because I was I was born in 74 I wasn't
really watching movies until about 80 81
where I was really you know you would
see things and all that's kind of cool
and you know your parents took you to
see Star Wars or whatever or you were
afraid of the shark in Jaws but you
weren't watching The Godfather you
weren't watching taxi driver so when I
discovered taxi driver in like 89 I was
like holy [ __ ] this is out there I
didn't know anything like this I didn't
know there could be anything like that
or Raging Bull or DePalma's I dressed to
kill her
I still remember all in the movies does
he taxi driver yeah I saw that movie at
the Mayfair theater and West near that
was a little too out there that movie
that movie when it came out like it was
known that it was gonna be a little too
out there it was too much for most
people and that movie [ __ ] my world up
yeah I still remember when I movie came
on TV for the first time I became one
Sunday night Sunday night TV all the
other they had to the whole the whole
ending well just about everything in it
has to go I still remember when national
TV ad Midnight Express
I saw Midnight Express in the movie
theater yeah I still remember watching
Midnight Express in my mother's
television she had a remote control with
four buttons on it yeah you got cable
that came with a string with three tears
with three tears
so the third tier was like all the dirty
channel hook if you didn't have the
dirty channels you could still put it on
the tier and there would be a line
across it you could still see like a
tick
yeah and her walking with a [ __ ] was
the creepiest tank there was the way but
when you watch your xi know you gotta
watch it and bang what happens you know
when we did judge off I'm be jerking off
to a crooked [ __ ] screen but wasn't
like you kids who could just punch some
[ __ ] into a computer
raising Lorena's crazy but I had like I
used to go to hotels I just played porn
you've got a hotel it just plays poison
oak Abel and they just play porn that's
it and it's the worst porn I throw Power
on Saturday night I drove past all the
old hotels to hang out with all those
little seedy hotel I'm totally Avenue
there was one on 91st Street that I
liked if I liked you think if I was near
me I'd take you there but if I was
[ __ ] I'd take it to the one the
bottom 83rd Street it was disgusting and
they have a room with a jacuzzi
definitely caught some time like the
sign like that they played xxx movies
that's it that's all that's in there
there's no TV there's no sports there's
no TV there's a TV all they play is
[ __ ] porno on Channel three [ __ ] and
sometimes they play the porno and I
would hear the guy next door call the
front desk
hey change the [ __ ] tape already will
ya it was [ __ ] crazy Lee it's [ __ ]
and the Hindu guys yelling back I take
the tape I put the tape in you want the
[ __ ] you know it's [ __ ] crazy when
they just have [ __ ] hotels and all they
have on Channel three that's it it's
just two people [ __ ] suckling just
sitting there with a girl you know how
many hotels I walked in with a girl like
like I walked in to do coke with a girl
and the first thing you do is turn
interior hoping for like nothing
happened that sexual harassment is so
just I just get on the TV yeah like even
if you don't want a [ __ ] you're gonna
[ __ ] as it's on the TV crazy
yeah the hotels as a kid was great cuz I
never at HBO so was my brother now oh my
god real sex is good like something like
that
I can't imagine just turning and finding
real how
that's it that was it and I'm not
talking about REO porn I'm talking and
porn porn porn re pulling ya fists
banging and [ __ ] big dicks in your face
yeah oh just ridiculous just disgusting
[ __ ] porn then there was a hotel on
69th Street that was kind of nice and
they had Sony Trinitron oh yeah so you
would steal an idea going in those days
New Jersey didn't have license to do
pictures of them and the camera and the
thing was a Fugazi yeah so he would
check in and take the TV with who robbed
the [ __ ] TV what about the guy whose
ID used the phone column if I found your
wallet lead beside the cash everything
in your wallet would be utilized for
something at one point you know once he
realizes what is missing start creating
an alibi because yeah yeah watch your
wallet was missing consider everything
even your library card what are the
[ __ ] abuse what if he had a Sony
Trinitron [ __ ] do you mean but if he
already had one and they come in this
house huh that's his problem
okay you right-handed no that's it I
wouldn't give a flea I didn't give a
Frenchman's [ __ ] oh if I went into a gym
and I thought you left your wallet no
longer as soon as you I saw you lifting
a jump in the pool I'd bang your [ __ ]
lock appeal see I knew guys like that
but I could never bring myself to do it
cuz I was always too scared I was all
the opportunity I can't I'm gonna
[ __ ] go you gotta try this being bad
they're going that bust him to that
[ __ ] Locker I did the creepiest [ __ ]
oh and I would use every piece of your
card eventual library everything
everything to the books
what do you mean the books like what are
you gonna do this library card like
whatever I could whatever I can finagle
there's always an angling it was crazy
if you're looking to make a dollar
there's always a weird illegal angle
that you can take there always is I
never forgot I worked a bar mitzvah one
time to find New Jersey and they had a
door yeah thought I had a key too uh I
think have given me gifts yeah
and like there was an office behind it
was my first night there mmm I got a
call from the American bartending
Institute are you available the Union
Hall are you available work this private
function at the alpine Country Club I'm
like absolutely I go down the outplaying
Country Club it's [ __ ] 20 million
Jews I don't care I got nothing against
used it was nice I mean they had good
food trusting in vitamin E and they had
this room over here and every 10 minutes
they put bags in there I mean handfuls
of bags and envelopes there was a stack
amylose oh yeah and I'm sitting there by
the [ __ ] bar by myself thinking throw
this thing and the final I hate uh-huh
the [ __ ] hits of the Jewish culture
they'll have to sit there thinking I got
a busted toilet and walls one took the
key and it took like ten of them and I
have a 10 involves firewood about Kashem
I said you know what I'm taking every
[ __ ] him up I took him God forgive me
I took every [ __ ] member I am t do
that I must have got I don't know how
much [ __ ] dough a lot dumb what you
thought I had when I walked in here hey
that way there's some Jewish kids still
thinking about that day I was though as
a Jewish kid they got cars that were
empty
I just got empty car I saw a lot of jugs
I left the checks oh my god I left the
gifts when that shift was over dog I
burned ass out of that thing before
anybody could find that what the [ __ ]
happened this had to be 1990 now 85 yeah
this was 32 [ __ ] years ago I robbed
the bar mitzva unbelievable talk about
revenge how do you make you do what you
gotta do that's that's what you were at
that time you know it's like yeah that's
crazy at the Alpine [ __ ] Country Club
I'm surprised it was that a country club
I didn't think they'd let us use in
there I've been the Jew country who
knows movies don't write note like
there's been a lot in the blonde with
Travolta when when what's that what's
that movie about the house whether they
move in and the [ __ ] in the house is
falling apart which house is falling
apart with Michael Keaton didn't Michael
Keaton do a movie about a he bought a
house oh no that's not that's not
Travolta it was a Pacific Heights
specific I think it's um Melanie
Griffith and Matthew Modine and they buy
a house to flip it and Michael Keaton's
is this [ __ ] psycho renter that won't
move out they can't get him out and yet
he does everything in his power to make
it even even worse yeah that was as I
was back in the early 90s I think it was
Pacific riots yeah 1990 yeah another
good movie about revenge that you have
to look at his revenge is what's the
movie DeNiro made what the crazy guy
he's a crazy guy which crazy guy and
it's a remake he torments Nick Nolte
Oh keep fear Cape Fear the originals
better though the original he original
yeah that like but when I finally saw
the ER because I had seen Cape Fear I
had seen the De Niro version and it was
good but then the Egyptians showed the
original months and I went to see it and
I was knocked on my ass it's black and
white yeah it's it's Gregory Peck
yeah it's Polly Bergen is the wife and
it's a Robert Mitchum as caddy and he
and his Mack KD and he's [ __ ] see with
DeNiro you get this cartoonish kind of
he's scary and he's easy he's creepy but
he's movie creepy Mitchum Mitchum looked
like a guy you could watch him in the
remake yeah they did it he played the
cop and got yeah he's just but Mitchum
had this cool style told me at this you
had this cool vibe to him where he was
hyper sexual but he was violent and you
got this sense that he was gonna do some
horrible [ __ ] to that family and it
didn't go down him in the same way that
it goes down in the the Scorsese throws
all this biblical [ __ ] intuitive
religion and and this dis avenging angel
kind of thing but what he is doing he is
going back on this family because in the
DeNiro version Nolte was his lawyer and
he buried a bunch of information that
could have kept him out of prison in the
other film in the mitchum film
I think Gregory Peck is a witness as as
dinner as Mitchum's character is getting
ready to rape a girl he stops him from
raping a girl so being the main witness
he's he goes after him because he's the
reason he's
seven years in prison but I'm telling
you man both of those films that level
of vengeance coming back on the it was
[ __ ] crazy
and I really I would I remember going my
god this is really great filming this is
with I still get excited when a Scorsese
films coming out I don't you don't get
you don't do it anymore it doesn't
I enjoyed the one with Jack Nicholson
the The Departed mmm whatever when he
did the one with the kid the walk or war
vote for Wall Street you didn't care for
that one too much I don't know that it's
done all get the same pattern he hasn't
blown my socks off and alone did you see
who go
no thanks atcha when watching when your
little girl gets a little bit older and
she can understand stuff because it's a
beautiful film it's really it's a kids
movie and you wouldn't suspect him of
being able to to put together a kids
movie but he's such a he's such a
consummate artist and he loves the movie
so much that he can go into that world I
mean this is guy that's made musicals
he's made documentaries he's made
religious films he's made biblical epics
he's made he's made crime dramas he's
done he's done comedies he's done
everything
are you excited about his little movie
the Irishman you know what I'm scared I
saw a poster today for Gotti what
happened with that you see the trailer
please regatta if there's a trail of
2018 I've seen a prettier trailer for
you did see yeah yeah look for volta
Travolta when Travolta is great there's
nobody better
Travolta really delivers he's just a
[ __ ] great he's a movie star but he
is a great actor but you know but it but
the movie star thing overwhelms
everything else that he does but that
movie was supposed to come out so long
ago and then he got buried and then I
thought I started think he was going to
start doing straight-to-video [ __ ] so
what's happening with it here it is
thank you what the [ __ ] he says cuz I
just saw the poster today strong strong
violence and pervasive language it's
you tell you soon New York is the
greatest city in the world
my city I was a kid in these streets and
I made it to the top I made my bombs
doing a piece of work for Don Carlo
Gambino like that I became the made man
that I'm thinking maybe take a year off
you wanna hang out with me
do you know what you're doing to this
family I will build something that
nobody can destroy silly well Casa la
was a fish in the desert
I never respected well you killed the
boss's boss you will bring down Hellfire
there is no choice you will need the
support of all five boroughs Queens
Brooklyn Manhattan Staten Island the
Browns
my job now is to maintain leadership I
nominate John Gotti let everybody off
now or but it comes to this I'm sure
proud you should be running your own
crew now mr. Gotti are you the head of
the Gambino crime family the head of
life family mrs. Bobby do you know your
husband does my living painter Claude
John's getting too much press that can't
go unchecked
it was meant for you
this kind of scrutiny before what are
you saying in the tapes I said a lot of
things that could get a lot of people in
trouble dad said word I'll go for a
cliff feed you that you would not bring
him into that well this life of ours is
a wonderful life if you can get away
with it Johnson has been an informant
for the FBI
you fight too you can't fight no more
never back off
you walk together and we fall together
this is the life they do it up so here's
my question cuz it doesn't mean as much
to me as it means to I think you guys to
me watching that trailer
I couldn't tell whatever year it was
1970 1980 it looked like a 2000 the cars
a little bit looking at 2018 movie to me
I'd rather see it looked like the
nineteen where I don't know what year he
was running around but he was running
around what mid 80 85 85 to what early
nineties hurt oh he wasn't rhythm he was
running around from late 62
I think 85 87 he found 85 was really
killed Castellano so it's the movies
dirty is late but HBO did a movie of
what they have did they have a Martin
Armond say come on decide yeah that was
tremendous yeah Anthony Quinn yeah
played uh the [ __ ] my boy whatever I'm
the boss it was great
I thought it was great I don't think
people you know listen right now I'm so
far taken away from movies yeah and it
breaks my heart that's why I like
talking to you and bring you in here
because you refresh me at least you let
me know but when I ask you you see they
didn't that floats you above nothing you
know I've seen some of the Oscar winners
in the last ten years and I sit there
and I go doesn't even look like Oscar
win this you know Brando look like an
Oscar winner yeah you know you looked at
most people they won't ask it it's not
about that no more
you know we know the waiter from the
Icehouse he worked for four years with
onstop
says he can't see had a job now was just
straight white guy you gotta be a twelve
diversity you know it's all baby it's
all diversity but I'm not seeing any
diversity on the screen so yeah well I'm
not seeing it all I want to see is a
[ __ ] movie yeah you follow me I don't
care who's in it what color the people
are huh
I'd rather see a movie the [ __ ]
entertains me that takes me somewhere
for two hours that makes me think about
what I just saw off for two hours ago
you know what I'm gonna go see that
[ __ ] movie again something about that
movie [ __ ] got me you know you know
what I
like I said blank out into comedy I gave
up a lot of [ __ ] and I start melon and I
went to prison well then when I came out
of prison you think I give a [ __ ] about
movies I gave a [ __ ] about good phone
but I never saw a major league in movie
theater yeah I love discovering a film
yeah I love discovering a gem you know
my wife does that my wife will say I
caught a movie and that wasn't for me
but it's gonna work for you and I'll
watch the moving tent she showed me
movie who are back with Misha we whoever
plays in the UM dying up here Melissa
the young man let Sally or which movie
talking about one about the Indians that
she crossed oh no no not when River uh
it was something about her to her get in
those Indians across that northern lake
well something like yeah Taysom man that
was a great [ __ ] yes it was
and there's movies that you don't it's
it's so weird that somebody said
something media day uh-huh well I went
to New Jersey I was talking to a guy
after the second show and it's something
like holy I feel bad sometimes I feel
bad because we didn't get to see the
best of the best
no it was chosen and picked between us
between the network's is [ __ ] like that
like that first episode of season one
alumni and I appear in court on the
plane there - saw me at my role thank
you for people watched it I really liked
Eric Griffin all that stuff that's the
tape I'm not even even animals are the
spirit of it yeah I liked you know it's
not an Academy Award winning but the
spirit of it is sometimes a movie is an
Academy Award winner but the spirit of
it I like Black Panther had me mm-hmm
until I saw the CGI the rhinoceros is
horrible I [ __ ] hate hated it hey all
that good time I was having a good time
yeah - see that's all that [ __ ] loses me
that's every movie today yeah
that's every movie they cut they say
they took something out of movies to
realism mm-hmm something real it they
really did they really did you know when
when that dude won
Hurt Locker mm-hmm that guy should and I
don't know him I'm not saying nothing
bad about here I didn't think that was
an oscar-winning performance no that was
far from what I expect
when I saw Pesci in Goodfellas I left
there going something's gonna happen I
have to gather delivered you know when I
see him dancing with Wolves I knew that
was a beautiful [ __ ] film like I
cried they're invincible world strong
twice you know I watched that the movie
with Mel Gibson played the Irish guy
Braveheart Braveheart yeah you know Ted
okay that dad listened and again I don't
want to be that guy
what does it take the movies you
remember the other put money into a film
like that again these are films that
have lasted back then we were seeing
good films and you were more likely to
see better films on a on a per chance
basis but the ones that we're talking
about are the ones that have lasted
there are a handful of films being made
right now that are good but they're just
fewer I mean III watch movies now and
I'm just like oh god when I go to see a
movie in a theater I'm usually not
really disappointed because I don't go
into it expecting that much but there
was a movie called um beautiful land or
something like that it was came out of
Australia and it was about these
Aborigines who who this Aborigines man
who killed a white man who raped his
wife and how they were hunting him down
and it was great it was beautiful to
look at it's still out there there's
still good [ __ ] to be found a lot of
good [ __ ] is also on TV now so you get
pulled into serials you know you get
pulled into a Sopranos or a dead wood or
a Breaking Bad or Game of Thrones or
whatever the [ __ ] people are watching
right now the industry changes but good
work is still there you can still find
good work
did you see um three billboards outside
of Hemmings Missouri the the Frances
McDormand film no I liked that it was
about a woman who who rents these three
billboards and she she makes a statement
on them basically saying why
haven't you found my daughter's rapist
and murderer oh yeah I heard it was good
it was really well made
Woody Harrelson is a great innit Frances
McDormand she for the year she deserved
the Oscar for that performance but
there's gonna be a handful of films like
that there's what we called god damn
there's a movie called Wind River you
get a chance see that if you have
Netflix watch The Wind River be good
about that diet that that was the Wind
River [ __ ] if they get some Wind River
it's the official Rob IANA again every
time you have fishy farts like that was
sea bass I know Jesus Christ jambalaya
for lunch chicken breasts pants but he
is gonna [ __ ] his pants one of these
days I know that's gonna happen already
don't bring your paper towel you wipe
the juice and you go back to what you
were doing you know the same time your
leg on this but you ever get it where
the the slot catches the laughs [ __ ]
I've had the brown in my sock and [ __ ]
man yes I have a couple years ago
shipped my bread no you can't it's
actually one down your pant leg yeah
think your socks off is it brown up at
the right on the hub you guys that were
in baggy pants so there's no how there's
no clean my pants I [ __ ] my pants a
bunch but like I usually catch it and
then I just go straight home wait you
talking about what the juice and keep
doing your days over that's why you were
the loose fitting Lysol sprayed on your
[ __ ] jeans animal have you ever [ __ ]
or paste your pants in the movies no no
really I've got the clothes cuz I I hate
getting up to go pee so I'll sit there
until the last possible minute
oh that's why I don't drink in a movie
theater anymore I'll eat I'll have the
pizza I'll have a sandwich whatever they
got to serve but if I have to drink if
they're gonna bring me a specialist
[ __ ] vats of coke that they bring you
I'm gonna piss before the end of this
[ __ ] movie I can't have that you know
then I miss some [ __ ] that I wanted to
sing now it's not only how Mel Gibson
when I want it after decides to make
movies you could see like Mel Gibson
made some great movies yeah he did make
a liquid ho hmm Braveheart you know all
the movies are the one about the
temptation of Christ
no did he put himself in there no he
wasn't in that no I gave his passionate
cry you know these guys they see they
caught all the way through I can't stand
I worked on every type of more yeah and
I remember during the law not even long
shirts buying a man - mm-hmm was one of
the first times I said Wow by spending a
lot of money
yeah they got pomegranate juice and I'm
killing it by the gallon this
[ __ ] pomegranate juice is like
three dollars a bottle and killing that
[ __ ] isn't it the best part of being on
set the food what you could ask that of
their Lord it's not anymore
that the look the last show that I
worked on dining a moment was so funky
add on anymore it's that that's a day
that all depends on the show mm-hmm
there's some shows that sailors I'm
taking all the money get the cheapest
food and some people go hey man I've
been on a set as an actor I've been
hungry I don't ever want that to happen
yeah take 10,000 on my salary and I want
[ __ ] I don't mind working 12-hour
days but let me tell you sir when I want
a bagel with lox there better be a bagel
I can chocolate cake
there better be chocolate cake there's
some movies you're our leader you can
ask for anything
yeah yes from bagel with lox they do a
lot bring me a bagel put some what I was
doing long as your honor I used to bring
Steve Simone Inari to the set and go I
was like let me have two pastrami
sandwiches with my brothers Jesus just
like that I would love to look at that
like that what they thought the catering
budget would be on your movies and then
what after like cuz if you if you're
selling jugs of pomegranate juice
you have no idea there was spider-man 2
that they hired a guy just to open the
door yeah but then I've done movies
where you walk yourself to set you bring
your own jeans
you know the [ __ ] there's nothing to
eat there's cheese packages one of those
crackers with peanut butter patties oh
yeah records like that thousand of those
popcorn in the bag and apples and
bananas they might give you peanut
butter and jelly that peanut bun like a
shadow to Johnny that [ __ ] goes quick
yeah cuz those are had the most go
through peanut butter and jelly like
[ __ ] like like the welfare people on
the fifth day [ __ ] tan that up on this
is telling the absolute truth oh my god
those people go what I just work on
guestbook they're a tremendous
tremendous yeah they were tremendous the
food was tremendous on the [ __ ] set
they didn't serve you lunch they give
you an hour to walk around which means
they give you thirty five hours yeah
pardon or nearly per diem they don't
give it to you that day they give it to
you in your check you could walk and go
eat but there was enough food on the set
now you didn't need and they brought it
in every four hours they brought in some
paneer Jesus you know yeah they did they
don't [ __ ] around but there's some sets
and what happened with me was and it was
funny I did a short film in a pizza
place they were paying me cash payments
all I cared about
no I get will pay you 2 days in cash
there was two nights of work and he goes
the second nice to be liked till two or
three but the first night you gonna be
on that quick but will pay you for the
night I said you need to pay me for gas
and I went up there the first night and
there was nothing I mean crackers and
waters yeah and the next night when I
got there it was the Taj Mahal because
the after rep was there huh and I asked
them I still have that dudes card he's
not after no more cuz it Birds me I was
like twelve years ago but I found this
card about a month ago I was going
through my cards he said the next time
you go on the set and it don't look like
the Taj Mahal
I wanted call me immediately I'll send
the [ __ ] rep over and find him on the
spot and after that I got really like I
did a movie called Boilermaker
great movie
but the second day I had a throw a
little [ __ ] fell out of a set all the
third day was a Sunday we were home
there was no food and I said listen
timeout Monday through Saturday you
don't want to have food I'm cool with
that but Sunday you took people away
from their families
you better get some [ __ ] full of this
cell on call me after rep they looked at
me dog they never liked me after that
yeah I had the director on the podcast
years ago yeah and he just started
liking me again and then he put me in
the movie and I couldn't do it so he
hates me that he put me in the movie
there was like 100 a three days I don't
want to be in a movie that bad I don't I
don't know it's it's it's gonna be a
[ __ ] you know I feel you know I
love doing the podcast I love doing
stand-up I love being on a set for a
limited time limited time it's really
weird I don't think I could do a wall
movie anymore
yeah nothing like that I don't think I
could do four days in a row on this I
think I'm losing my [ __ ] mind at the
dream I had when I first got here being
on a TV show that left that left I don't
mind doing an episode of two or three
but every week no more uncle Joey that's
a weird thing to say and say I don't
know unless I fell in love with the RO a
lesson they train unless I can do like a
Tracy Morgan role on third Rock where
you call me in early and get me out of
there by 12:00 1:00 or 2:00
amen guarantee me that thing I'm gonna
get me out of it cuz I'm fidgety you
know I'm saying I'm too old and too
[ __ ] fidgety and you want me in there
for comic relief I'm in yeah about 12
hour days 14-hour days I can't do those
let's see for me though like when I'm
working extra I hate you can either work
you can either work me three hours and
get me the [ __ ] out of there or I want
to work 14 hours I want that [ __ ]
because because eight hours is the
regular day three hours they're gonna
pay you eight I get out of there early
that's great 9 to 10 hours that's time
and a half
10 to 12 hours that's double time and if
you make it to that 15th hour they're
supposed to pay you your your day rate I
figure I'm not doing anything else and
I'm sitting here and I'm watching and
I'm trying to pay attention to you know
I'm trying to get to know these uh these
these production assistants and trying
to figure out how they're moving the
camera and I love being on set I love it
it's it's if I have to go to [ __ ]
Santa Clarita or Long Beach or San Pedro
or if I gotta go to one of those studios
I'm ok with all of that as long as I get
to as long as I get to see how it's I
liked all that thought yeah I love when
I was watching Greg Rossi I love what M
directors I loved watching exactly I
haven't been doing it as long as you
though so that's that I've always
admired you know I was thinking about
that today I was driving back and I was
thinking about questions to hit you with
yeah you know I think the word director
has also been mere [ __ ] up I think
that too many people with cameras have
called themselves the Wranglers a
director in other words for me what it
means to me is he's gonna read the
script 15 times and then tell me a
[ __ ] story
yeah tell me a story how he sees it with
his shots yeah with his lighting with
his I see these movies they all look the
same to me now they all do now okay you
know that's what these are little things
I notice and like a [ __ ] I don't have
time to [ __ ] out a wife and a kid I
don't know what do I know what do I give
a [ __ ] of the world but these are the
things that turn me off about the film
industry when I went to see angel heart
the fact that the movies dark it's just
dark it gets dark all the way through
the director park of that year knows the
shafts of light shooting through that
elevator is it's all that stuff
beautiful tool a beautiful okay I
understood that I don't see that anymore
yeah I don't know if it's me if it's the
studio's if it's a director if it's the
coordinator I don't know what it is
anymore I don't get to see that in a
film
anymore you know even yeah I watch
splash last week oh my god
last week there were two movies on one
night Lee called me and I actually had
to tell her you had a qualify yeah blind
date was a oh wow Bruce Willis Willis
came Basinger John Larroquette John
Larroquette brilliant [ __ ] when they
will we put on last week I was [ __ ]
Howland yeah
you know a simple comedy hmm and she
carried it yeah she was the [ __ ]
force how to eat I'm saying like she
should have done 20,000 comedic roles
after that you know what happened she
was too pretty she was too pretty and
you can't have they couldn't sell that
they wanted her to be sexy they wanted
because I think the next thing that she
did after that that was big was nine and
a half weeks and then she was a sex
kitten for the rest of her career then
she did that movie with Richard Gere in
87 which I really enjoyed but Richard
Gere where she belongs to a gangster in
New Orleans mm-hmm Richard Gere goes
down there and he [ __ ] investigates
the thing yeah buys her from her she
explains to him that mm-hmm
the guy bought Kim Basinger when she was
a girl hmm
like the parent border from the parents
when she was 16 so Richard Gere tries to
take her away what's the fine can't
remember that we'll see if you can find
that Richard Gere Richard a mishap no
way out no it's not no way out that's
the Kevin Costner film with Sean Young
and Hackman Kim Basinger Richard Gere no
mercy no no mercy yeah that I haven't
thought about that movie oh my god in
fact the guy that plays the husband
what's the movie with Nick Nolte and and
Barbra Streisand the princes the Prince
of tides Prince of tides and plays a
husband he's the violin player make the
sound an affair mm-hmm
he plays the bad guy in a movie now if
you watch The Prince of tides yeah the
guy's a dick mm-hmm the guy's a dick you
could tell by his face you know about
his walk everything he's a dick but if
you watched no mercy you learn the
camerawork you're gonna see that he
makes this guy look like black laughter
yeah you don't know
Wow yeah and then you're gonna see the
guy in that movie know who either he was
that good of an actor or because when
did when did Prince of tides come on
ninety-one baby
maybe 190 around there I was out I
wasn't locked up no way out came out in
87 91 bein in one so no way out came out
in 97 89 88 87 hmm
so in four years the guy didn't lose
that much muscle no and he played so
[ __ ] intimidating this guy even in my
movie seat was intimidating to me just
[ __ ] sitting there but it's weird how
the director shot him low yeah and made
him look ginormous
mm-hmm that's always baffled me that's
what I'm talking about the school when
you have a director who really knows
what the camera is capable of and they
can they know they know the lens that
they need to use they knew they needed
they know how far they need to be a way
they know how intimate the scene needs
to be hard work just don't have that a
lot of directors because I think now you
had you had directors who at one point
have lived lives you know by the time
John Huston was writing and directing I
think Treasure of the Sierra Madre mall
Torres Maltese Falcon he had had a life
he had traveled the world he had been on
all kinds of adventures he loved movies
but he had lived so it informed the
films that he was making I think the
problem was was today is that you got
every director taking every director
trying to be Tarantino what's out it's a
da cut for the [ __ ] do you gonna do a
cooked a fan of the podcast came to the
show in Jersey yeah and it was funny you
should leave that at the office I'm like
thank you safe this is my man detective
Stephen gates retired right but it's
funny that then I met a lot of cops were
one home yeah and I was talking to one
cop and we're talking about policing
mm-hmm he was telling me how he was
happy he retired because what happened
to the police
heroes is that now they're all college
you can yeah it's like where if you grew
up in North Hollywood you become a lot
Hollywood cop and you're this is your
home
yeah I know all the nooks and crannies
and when he was telling me was when I
became a cop eating ice cream the bomb
he goes now they give the college kids
who've never really lived yeah they
don't have interactions they don't know
the neighborhood and that's why they
quick to pull a trigger that's why you
have all these shootings that have made
sense to me yeah I didn't understand
what was going on I go so what you mean
the town we right now in New Brunswick
there's no cop that walks the beat he
goes that's a thing of the past
yeah a beat cop is a thing of the past
Lee you've never seen a beat cop only in
movies holy that's amazing
you know any time you put a police
officer in a uniform in a neighborhood
it strengthens that neighbor here
because you know he's around the core
even in Boston I didn't see it yeah
that's really [ __ ] weird
every neighbor like North Hollywood
should have a walking cop by that Park
because then the homeless people know
all those people know they gotta be in
check every hour on the hour he's gonna
come by well that was a kid there was a
cop that walked by you every two hours
yeah but you knew you did some he'd be
there in ten [ __ ] seconds yeah so you
didn't do dick
you know one time he was called
something that's quite what a cop wears
the uniform it's not the Tarrant it's um
one of the biggest crime deterrent you
can have I know that there's a cop on
the corner yeah it's gonna be a big
crime Tutera for me you know so many
things have changed like that because
with they all go to USC and they all
wear the same tricks or they have the
budgets to be creative yeah I mean for
Christ's sakes these movies have the
budget sterling granted one thing about
Black Panther the story helped me it was
great it was really great they used some
great stuff they did some big girl was I
took the girl stole the movie no be
tellin ya yeah I thought she stole him
and then what about I Michael B Jordan
that he was great
he's really great well everybody was
good but the sister stole the so she was
my favorite Tina Turner was in the movie
but today Angela Bassett was new movie I
was waiting for [ __ ] like the pop out
of somewhere myself like the [ __ ] out of
her it's always a pleasure having you
what's
yes watch this with Rick Ramos watch
this with rick run almost if anybody
knows about movies this [ __ ]
knows the date the director what else he
did what he ate for breakfast and that's
a quality you can't find a lot of people
it's as my father-in-law said you have
the capacity to to withhold a lot of use
of the information yeah shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] at least I'm happy mind your
[ __ ] business like I said the
beginning of the show if you're looking
to get healthy you travel a lot you stop
with the [ __ ] water bottle if you
travel a lot did we do all these things
you want to be protected from the germs
you see these Japanese people walking
around with masks that's why you think
they do it they don't they don't know
about [ __ ] shroom tech immune they
don't know about this [ __ ] me I know
about shroom tech immune and when I fly
a pop four of them and tip top Magoo I
can make out with a crack ho and come
home with no [ __ ] flu you understand
me
shroom tech immune shoot export the
[ __ ] buy the mushroom and large is
your [ __ ] oxygen they tested up there
and high-altitude all that stuff then
you got the alpha brain you haven't
probably remember you having problems
remembering things you having problems
focusing this is the [ __ ] hundred
percent guarantee you get from them if
alpha brain you don't feel nothing you
get your money back and they don't want
the product man who does that time when
you buy tires they let you keep the
tires [ __ ] no that's how much they stand
behind their [ __ ] probably going on
it doc calm right now press Enter
BAM and get 10% off number two you're a
fat [ __ ] you can't find a gainer fit you
you got a big calf you can't find the
shin guard in going time your answers at
Fuji sports calm they've been there
since Japan got bombed you know I'm
saying they've been there Fuji Sports
has been there for [ __ ] two hundred
[ __ ] years making top-quality light
G's whether you're into competing
whatever if you need Agee mats whatever
you need do me a favor
pressing on code Church and get 10% off
how about the podcast we're here with
we're we're not killing you with [ __ ]
ads trying to insult you intelligence
I want to thank Rick Ramos again I want
to thank the [ __ ] [ __ ] number
one again that bong hit put him in
[ __ ] law out low and I want to thank
you guys and the guys that came out for
the stress factory in Providence again
for coming out and making a great
weekend
see you guys Wednesday afternoon with
mr. head Quinn I love your [ __ ]
stay black